and if we threaten our own food system  with these stupid rules about not using  nitrogen or carbon dioxide maybe they're  going to ban carbon dioxide in  greenhouses the next thing you know  people are working in there in CO2  levels two and three times what it is in  the atmosphere and actually right in  this room now CO2 will be at least  double what it is out in the air  because of our breathing we breathe out  two pounds of CO2 every day and the you  know the atmosphere is now 420 parts per  million CO2 when we exhale it's 40 000  parts per million CO2 because we're  taking in oxygen and breathing out CO2  the plants take in CO2 and breathe out  oxygen so it's a perfect cycle  and that's how that's nature in a  nutshell and people are not being even  educated about that